but first first guys the deep state
blitzkrieg continues the Russia
investigation is heating up with 49
questions that special counsel robert
muller wants to ask President Trump they
will ask you questions you don't know
what they know and they will trap you
there's a lot of rope here for the
president to notoriously off-the-cuff
speaker like the president well he could
walk right into a perjury trap what no
way hey stir up the kind of guy who
would walk into a perjury trap or hang
himself with rope or step on a rake that
stepped backwards onto another rake that
hits him on the back of a head and
knocks him into a swimming pool no the
answer is no hope opposers this is big
molars questions for Trump have been
revealed
I always knew Muller would come for
Trump with knives and buy knives I mean
questions that were shared in advance
with his legal team as a courtesy plus
these questions were leaked to the New
York Times and everyone knows we can't
trust that Muller has dozens of
enquiries for Trump on a broad quest of
Russian ties
I am told by my sources tonight that the
New York Times is full of crap yes yes
he's so articulate the New York Times is
full of crap so says Sean Hannity
sources who I'm told are John Baron and
David Dennison
that one with the beard was almost
casteist or until they told him he was
too strong and sexy plus if you look
through these questions almost all of
them are focusing on trumps motivation
and none of them are multiple choice
true or false or click on all of the
pictures that include a car questions
it's totally unfair
you can't ask Trump open-ended questions
Fox and Friends asked him what he got
Melania for her birthday and he talked
for 30 minutes and the answer was
nothing yep
she talked she likes to talk also the
questions were organized into four main
topics Russia Comey Michael Flynn and
Jeff Sessions if you're going to start
adding categories all willy-nilly
at least give Trump a couple he can ace
like ordering off the dollar menu and
forgetting Eric's fishing trips clearly
he would ace it clearly Trump is in
dangerous territory if the president
lies under oath that's called perjury
and it's a crime if he tells the truth
well he might hypothetically admit to a
crime that's a tough needle to thread
and like I tell my kids stay away from
needles that's where you find drugs and
autism causing vaccines
[Music]